language
offset turns Premiere Knight into a
family affair stepping out with his sons
to celebrate Spider-Man across the
spider verse gotta show up show love so
support
[Music]
on track hit the red carpet with all
three of his boys 13 year old Jordan
eight-year-old Cody and there's his and
cardi B's youngest wave rocking Shades
just like dad and his Bros
[Music]
and if these looks seem familiar the fam
likely set out to channel Michael
Jackson the late King of Pop and Spidey
both well known for their red ensembles
and a B in Spanish
[Music]
when you think about your character in
this movie what are you most proud of
that we have a representation of this
beautiful black and Latino family where
the father is there for his son these
families exist and flashback three weeks
ago
that's offset again on Hollywood
Boulevard this time for a daddy
daughter's date night at The Little
Mermaid premiere
I Wanna Be where the people are
eight-year-old Khalifa and four-year-old
culture were both on theme Looking ready
for royalty and black and white ball
gowns
on the blue carpet the girls first met
Holly Sister Chloe and later inside
culture came face to face with Ariel
herself Hallie Bailey
[Music]
it feels absolutely amazing to
officially be a Disney princess
something about you seems different I
can't quite figure it out she got legs I
know you have had to see these videos
that we've all been seeing of these
little girls especially these little
black girl seeing you seeing your image
and how they react to just seeing you
what has that been like for you it's
been such a beautiful moment for me to
be able to see the reactions of the
babies it makes me just emotionally
overwhelmed honestly and I cry as soon
as I watch them
starting right now
I think of the little girl that's still
in me honestly and it heals that girl
inside of me and to watch them feel like
they have representation and someone to
look to to know that they deserve to be
in those spaces too is so important part
of that
yep whether it's web slinging in the Big
Apple or looking for love under the sea
offsets making sure his little ones get
to see themselves represented on the big
screen
foreign